Hey are you okay in there I can hear you  get a proposal stand back  are you okay holy surprise whoo oh mama  ha okay okay this is new I mean no not  new right cuz we've seen this obviously  that whole magic thing is involved again  it was magic right actually you know  what you don't need to tell me I'm just  gonna go ahead and say your hair  magically grew back I'm not gonna ask  how obviously you don't want to tell me  or else you wouldn't have tried to hide  it from me so I won't ask how go back  but tell me please how did it go back  don't answer that the important thing is  you're okay you are okay right because  as long as you're okay I don't care what  happened I mean I care obviously I care  but I'm sure there's a reasonable  explanation where is the war that you'll  share when you're ready thank you for  understand  [Music]